before we begin I'd like to give a shout
out to the sponsor of this video some in
this war summoners war is an
action-packed fantasy turn-based RPG
with over a hundred million players
around the world now what I personally
like about this game is that there are
weekly in-game events in a global PvP
arena where you can real-time battle
with other users worldwide
right now summoners war is celebrating
their sixth anniversary by giving away
100 free summons this games absolutely
free to downloads to scroll down to the
description box and click on the link to
download it I think at this point there
are a lot of content creators out there
talking about the newest and hottest
anime in town here's the thing though
newer shows tend to run for shorter
episode runs and an anime having a
hundred episodes or more has become a
lost art it's not for me to say whether
the new model is strictly better or not
but let's just say a lot of people are
discouraged by a high episode count due
to a massive time investment now we all
seem to have a lot of time on our hands
now don't we so why don't we start
talking about the longest shows let's
face it that juicy little backlog you
have in your computers looking more and
more appetizing now isn't it yeah with
the amount of time that we have how
about using this time to start watching
those long long series that everyone's
been talking about so for today's video
we'll have something a bit different
we'll be going through some of the best
long-running anime you can binge watch
while you're stuck at home specifically
shows which have more than a hundred
episodes without further ado let's start
with the list I'm not sure if I cheated
by compiling the entire mana garden a
series as one entity but it is what it
is isn't it mana kata is a story about
go Yomi araragi and his experiences with
several people who fell victim to
problems caused by oddities a fancy way
of saying Shinto spirits in contrast to
what you typically expect out of a
series like this the oddities are
typically not dealt with through
fighting a representation of a
character's innermost desires of flaws
the oddities are dealt with by coming to
terms with said flaws
something which kayo me helps the
numerous characters do that's not to say
that monogatari is entirely devoid of
action I featured some of the most
notable fights in character scenes in
several previous videos and that's more
of a testament to how well the series
weaves high-octane action
scenes with its dialogue and
character-building keep in mind this is
one of those stories which isn't told in
chronological order so people do keep on
asking you more order should I watch
this series now to that I'd say just
stick to the released order or just
pause the video and take a screenshot of
this overall Monogue Arthur Lee is one
of the best series that you can watch
when it comes to modern anime despite
appearing to have cliched characters the
series does do a good job at subverting
expectations and developing some of the
most fascinating characters with clever
dialogue and plot progression
next up on the list we have a pretty
old-school classic it's bleach bleach
tells the story of ichigo kurosaki a
tough no-nonsense high school student
who has the ability to see ghosts his
life takes a steep turn one fateful
night when he meets Rukia Kuchiki
introducing herself as a Soul Reaper
Rukia shows Ichigo the world of souls
and the dangers that lie within
including hollows that prey on human
souls
Rukia herself gets put in danger against
one such Hollow while protecting
ichigo's family in his desire to protect
Rukia in his family it ago takes up the
mantle of being the substitute Soul
Reaper taking in rukia's powers a new
hero is born and the rest is history
challenging enemies new friends and foes
and more mysteries of ichigo's birth and
origins await in this long-winded
supernatural action series bleach is one
of the more popular anime that took the
world by storm in the 2000s I personally
like the show's powers and aesthetics
more than its peers and I think that it
ago is a great protagonist as far as
style and coolness go
despite its notoriety with filler arcs
bleach does have some really immersive
ones including the zanpakuto arc and the
rare guy arc
if fanservice and modern anime tropes
aren't for you there maybe you could go
for a more gritty and hot-blooded show
for the next entry on the list may I
introduce to you Hajime no Ippo
introverted and soft-spoken if Bo
doesn't have a lot of things to look
forward to in life perpetually bullied
his fate would take a turn for the
better once he meets professional boxer
taka Mora who gets encouraged as seeing
his powerful punch having a new goal in
life a PO joins the world of boxing in
his bid to become a champion and
discover the true meaning of strength an
oldie but goodie Hajime no Ippo ought to
bring out the hot blood in you in its
epic showdowns and characters worth
cheering for it's one of the pioneers
and best examples of Sports anime
through and through another good thing
about it is that you don't need a lot of
knowledge about sports and boxing to
enjoy it if you're someone who enjoys
and wants to see some of the most
intense and climactic anime fights
Hajime no Ippo would be a welcome
addition to your watchlist there's no
better time to join a pose long winded
journey to reach the top than the
present
before bleach was a thing there was a
show called yuu-yuu hakusho starring a
delinquent who gets an unexpected
one-way trip to the spirit world you can
clearly see some elements that have
become a staple in supernatural shows in
modern times the numerous arcs all
served to showcase Takashi's genius even
before he went on to write his arguably
better work Hunter hunter that's what
you you hakusho I love the creativity
being put on display through the
different powers narrative structures
and character writing the fights are
especially good and it's multiple
episode one will surely take you through
twists and turns that you won't regret
experiencing it's an all-around great
series that was a lot bigger back in the
90s and were somewhere around on par
with Dragon Ball well at least in Japan
anyway I'd say age quite decently and
it's never too late to start on after
all it was one of the best-selling
titles back then and deservingly so
a perennial favorite of the ones
watching anime in the 2000s Naruto has
since they've done with an underwhelming
sequel boruto but as far as the original
one is concerned it's carved out a
pretty nice legacy for itself that you
think I think so many fans have grown up
watching and following Naruto's journey
to becoming Hokage and a hero that
everyone looks up to being an outcast
and a general loser those dreams seem to
be light-years away for our plucky ninja
however this is one guy who never knows
when to quit and give up despite all the
challenges in his way he surely finds a
way to get to the top the notorious
amount of fillers might bum you out a
little bit but once again you can always
skip through those overall Naruto as a
series is a long and great journey
revolving around friendship redemption
and forgiveness
[Music]
a list of long runners definitely
wouldn't be complete without one piece
possibly the definition of a long runner
for most anime fans spanning over two
decades already one pieces remained
strong and continues to assert its
dominance over much of the Shonan fandom
to this day how does it do so with an
open world that's ripe for adventure
Luffy's adventure in search of one piece
has taken him through all kinds of
places in the high seas in numerous
adventures and battles the one piece
world is cleverly designed for such a
long narrative and thanks to olders
writing style and creativity the series
just doesn't seem to get old one piece
is home to all sorts of characters that
are a pleasure to me to note as well as
some of the most memorable heroes and
villains in anime history I won't mince
my words even though one piece is
probably my personal favourite shounen
manga of all time the anime does drop a
few places due to some issues like poor
pacing in cannon feathers and
inconsistent animation one piece is
truly a daunting anime to tackle if
you're looking for a catch-up trip as
they say the adventure or the journey is
its own reward meme Lords will love this
next entry in terms of sheer
over-the-top content and say that it's
practically impossible to top JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure the franchise that
started in the late 80s and is still
going strong today the fights and
characters are so crazy and over the top
the people have grown enamored of the
series especially in the fight sequences
nothing's too crazy or out of the world
for JoJo's Bizarre Adventure to the
point of ridiculousness and not in a bad
way I mean look at the art style and
powers alone doesn't that scream mean
material for you the jokes and fun
discussions just write themselves at
this point there are loads of things to
draw you into JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
and since we've got the time right now
why don't you start off from the very
beginning it's never too late to join in
on the fun
among the numerous anime that have more
than a hundred episodes
Gintama is probably one of the more
unique ones it's unique in a sense that
it's one of the shows that can seemingly
go 180 or will others would have the
impression that the shows really comedy
focus with its previews and hook however
once you get to the meat of the story
Gintama can suddenly do an about-face
and throw a serious and emotional arc at
us I think it's this amazing part of
Gintama that sets it apart from a lot of
other shown in titles it doesn't take
itself too seriously but when it does
you better watch out Ginn Toki and the
rest of the eurozone are all have
captivating stories to tell and all
those arcs slowly build up to a
satisfying conclusion at the end of over
300 episodes if the 300 plus episodes
aren't enough for you there are also a
couple of movies that will be fun to
watch as well honestly if you're new to
the world of anime I wouldn't recommend
watching Gintama yet as it does have a
lot of references and parodies from
dozens of other shows which you may not
pick up during the first watch but
overall Gintama is a flawlessly executed
series with a great blend of comedy
action and emotion which is cemented
itself as one of my favourite anime of
all time
if you are some of the most ardent
Shonen fans online what the best shown
in anime is I'm sure that a lot of them
would point you to talk I Xi's
masterpiece Hunter hunter and for good
reason - hunter hunters a series that's
connected with multiple generations of
fans you don't just connect with the
multiple generations for nothing despite
all the memes and jokes about its
numerous hiatuses Hunter hunter proves
to be one of the best in world building
and character development through its
numerous genre shifts and creative ways
in trying out different formulas the
series has come up with some of the best
characters and story arcs and shown in
history with a great cast of characters
action and consistently great animation
hunter hunter will remain a tail for
anyone to enjoy don't find a large
episode count daunting in any way
because the journey will definitely be
worth it now that's a lot of shows for
you to sync your time into hell you
might even have all the time in the
world and still not be able to finish
some of these in a short time tell me
which one you're gonna watch during a
long break if there are any other long
run is that you'd recommend then I want
to hear from you too now if you enjoy
content like this make sure to LIKE and
subscribe as well as hit the bell button
so you can get the first updates for new
videos don't forget to check out our
sponsors game summoners war links in the
description by downloading you'll be
really helping this channel out and
you'll be playing a great game for free
I'll see you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]